but it is here the night Democrats in
Washington honestly been dreading for
weeks impeachment has obscured this but
trust me in the mind of every Democratic
consultant and office holder in DC has
been tonight the first voting of the
2020 primary season as is so often the
case pretty much everything the
illiterate supposing as political
analysts you see in your television
screen once predicted has turned out to
be wrong remember they told you that
Bernie Sanders had no chance to win that
the race was really between Joe Biden
Elizabeth Warren baitoey Rourke and
Kamla Harris it all seems pretty amusing
now now that Beto's going back to
skateboarding and Harris is dropped out
and Warren is still in the race but
there's no plummeting toward Earth Joe
Biden has wandered off to find the
desert card why the help kit man get a
decent slice of rhubarb pie in this
place he's wondering Bernie Sanders
meanwhile is actually now the
front-runner in the Democratic
nomination race and this is the
nightmare scenario for the Democratic
establishment in Washington they're
suddenly hoping against hope that Amy
Klobuchar gets some gravity tonight and
some votes and in the meantime they're
putting in frantic calls to a certain
authoritarian New York mayor who also
happens to have sixty billion dollars in
the bank save as' tiny billionaire save
us the rest of us have a lot to enjoy
this primary season but there's also a
lot to learn by watching it so watch it
Sanders running on a premise that you
might recognize actually if you voted
for Donald Trump in 2016 the system is
rotten and corrupt elect me and I will
fight for you except in this case with
Bernie there's some evidence that he
will also tear down a lot of it maybe
all of it so far Sanders has promised to
use executive orders to open the borders
just in case you didn't think the
country was changing fast enough already
Sanders wants to ban hydraulic fracking
which would shudder America's most
productive economic sector and make us
once again dependent on Middle Eastern
theocracies Sanders promises it will all
be fine though because the green new
deal which not incidentally will give
him total control of a huge portion of
the American economy so there's that and
then he says he'd nationalize our health
care system and make private insurance
illegal he'd hiked the top tax income
bracket he'd impose a wealth levy on
those he thinks have too much and that's
just for starters so the Democratic
Party's funders on Wall Street in in
silicon
Valley don't like the sound of this the
new taxes especially they love lifestyle
of liberalism when it means legal weed
and raunchy halftime shows and
non-binary bathrooms that stuff is free
and in fact you can make money on the
weed and they are but tightening the tax
code now
no thanks they're not into that at all
so this called their friends over on CNN
the digital bodyguard of the ruling
class and they begged for help and CNN
delivered as it always does just days
before the last debate CNN ran an
utterly unproven hit piece on Sanders
calling him a sexist and then they went
further you're saying that you never
told senator Warren that a woman could
not win the election that is correct
senator Warren what did you think when
senators Andrew Sanders told you a woman
could not win the election I disagreed
see he's a sexist just like Donald Trump
and that was the signal to all the other
establishment toady's to pile on which
they obediently did Paul Krugman waddled
out from his cubicle at the New York
Times to call Bernie Sanders a liar
Craven hack John cheat of New York
Magazine did what he was told as he
always does and he called Sanders
surgeon active insanity David Fromm at
the Atlantic reassured his panicked
readers that Bernie can't win but of
course none of them really believed that
or they wouldn't be writing these pieces
in the first place they know Sanders
could win and they're worried about it
and honestly in some level you can't
blame them for being worried about it
Sanders is a human bug light every
lunatic and the Democratic Party seems
drawn to him and absorb Lee they can't
stay away most of Alexandria Kazu
Cortez's squad for example has endorsed
him they're on the road for him just the
other day his surrogate congresswoman
Rasheeda Talib reminded the country how
she earned her reputation as the single
most unappealing member of Congress
watch you guys remember last week when
someone by the name of Hillary Clinton
said that nobody we're not gonna boo
we're not gonna boo we're classy hero
[Music]
you all know I can't be quiet no we're
gonna boot that's alright the haters the
haters will shut up on Monday when we
win well mondays come and we're gonna
find out in just a moment if they have
won not that it really matters because
no matter where he places in Iowa
tonight Bernie Sanders is not going away
and neither are his supporters the
Democratic Party is going to be dealing
with these people for months and months
if not years and you can't say it's not
deserved